I'm Vanessa Kirby and this is your
weekend ticket new in theaters this
weekend Fast and the Furious presents
Hobbes and Shaw
what will you see this is your weekend
ticket
[Music]
[Music]
in the car we're all going no you
I said we're all going the first
spin-off of The Fast and Furious
franchise hits theaters this weekend in
Hobbs and sha look off new system when
Deckard shot played by Jason Statham
learns that his sister is in over her
head in the pursuit of an eco-terrorist
weapon he steps in to help her but so
does Shaw's rival agent Luke Hobbs who
is there for reasons of protecting the
world from this dangerous threat when
it's the fate of the world it becomes my
business his whole thing sounds really
don't you
now the unlikely three must work
together to keep the weapons safe from
Brixton lower played by Idris Elba a
rogue agent bent on using it to destroy
half the world's population oh and he
basically has superpowers
yeah he really is black Superman this
movie is for you if you're a fan of The
Fast and Furious franchise you're
looking for a fun action movie this
summer or if you love that sweet sweet
fast and furious physics logic like when
Dom caught Letty in Fast and Furious 6
not a scratch
that's our Dom family he does say family
in this trailer I was so worried that
they were gonna say family in the movies
my sister family business that is your
weekend ticket what will you see and
check back next week for some movies
from things from your childhood
[Music]